and now time Ruby Rose debuted Batwoman
today first look image that's very
exciting
I had my first official day on the
crossover even though tactically it kind
of started last week because they
condensed my episode before the
crossover but I now officially into the
crossover we actually shot the first
scene from the first hour of the
crossover scene 1 and scene - I'm very
excited to say that I get to open the
crossover this year which is a huge
honor and I'm in a place that no one
could ever expect me to be ever this
will begin to crystallize we're gonna
have some cool stuff to show you guys
later this week and yeah just getting
into the crossover and feeling very very
thankful and grateful that we're getting
so many cool toys to play with this year
you know getting to work with Ruby and
getting it work with Tyler and just
getting to work with people that I've
never worked for before and weird stuff
that I've never worn on the show before
and have things that I've never had in
the show before and you know maybe yeah
well I can't spoil too much I would I
would stay around the interwebs on
Thursday morning though mm-hmm Thursday
morning
additionally very excited to announce
that for the first time ever ever since
I started shooting the show we are gonna
be shooting content that's going to
appear in the crossover not Vancouver
believe it or not I'm going to an
American city that I had never filmed
him before and I couldn't be more
excited and just in case I'm not
supposed to say anything about it that's
all that I'm gonna say for the time
being hey everybody it's Charlie a whole
bunch of new flash and crossover stuff
to talk about I'll talk about the
crossover stuff first then I'll break
down this flash footage the whole
episode cut up into flash time
frames from each scene in the episode
although they slow that down a little
bit so that you could catch some of the
dialogue but some of it was just really
sped up there's a new brand of the flash
ring giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
Flash related comment on the video I'll
name a winner at the end of this Stephen
Amell talks about filming footage for
what sounds like the crossover in a city
that he's never filmed in before best
bets are that's either gonna be the
Gotham City from wherever Batwoman is
from whichever earth that winds up being
or that could be where the prison is
were Oliver's out because he does have
to get out of prison for the crossover
but there's still a couple of ways that
you could explain how he's in the
crossover without necessarily getting
out of prison although I do think that's
part of the idea is that he'll get out
then go into the second half of arrow
season out of prison going after the
longbow hunters he also says that he's
opening the crossover he said he filmed
a couple of moments from the first hour
of the crossover already in
chronologically they're going to be
scenes with Oliver so just remember that
the order of the crossover episodes is
going to be different from what the
actual broadcast days are so Supergirl
is a Sunday night show now arrow is
Monday night in Flash's Tuesday night
but when they released that first promo
picture they gave you the new order so
the first part will be flash on Sunday
night arrow will be on Monday night
December 10th and then the next night
the last night will be Supergirl maybe
because they want to tease ongoing
smaller crossovers with just those two
characters to play up the Batman
Superman world's greatest of it all
recently they were also filming footage
for the Supergirl part of the crossover
and he tweeted this picture out with
everybody's weapons out on the pool
table
so he's posting more stuff from behind
the scenes more than any of the other
actors they're gonna be filming all
those episodes for several more weeks
it's gonna be a while so we'll be
getting a lot more of this stuff if they
drop any big bombs or anything like that
I will totally put it in the other
related videos that I'm doing like the
flash trailers or the arrow videos so
flash time episode 2 a lot of this
footage you may recognize from earlier
promos that they've released it starts
off with cicada inside what looks like
this warehouse here probably coming for
one of the medes during the episode
there's one main meta that they're going
after that tries to box Barry in but it
sounds like there are others going on
too because you see him taking down a
couple people during this you see Cisco
elongated man looking at Nora's version
of the future newspaper from even
further in the future just going oh my
god I can't believe this this seems like
another cicada takedown of another
character just to give you a better
explainer for what happens when he uses
his special speed for stacker then you
see him drop it inside a locker room the
way they explained his character is that
he is a very blue-collar villain he's
supposed to be a totally normal dude
that's empowered by the stuff that's
been happening in Central City because
of all the Dark Matter explosions you
know the experiments that the thinker
was running you see Barry walk into the
warehouse Nora is with him it looks like
she has a little badge that says
consultant so because she's a CSI in the
future she's actually qualified to help
out on these cases but because of the
way they're using the character she'll
probably derp and get a little overeager
about it we learned that this
containment power that this med has when
she's taking down Barry can actually
crush people into small cubes because
this small looking meat cube is an
actual human body compressed to that
size they break up a couple shots of
them running across the city Nora back
in her suit in action getting ready to
fight someone with Barry more of her
training with him showing her highlight
reels of him training from early in
season one getting his butt kicked the
funny classroom scene of her trying to
throw lightning and throwing him a right
through that play glass it's okay I've
been hit by lightning before this person
in the wheelchair might be related to
the ongoing CSI investigation they're
conducting during the episode but in the
context of what they're doing with the
cicada villain he's probably there to
set up part of his motivation to convey
the idea that this escalation of powers
is hurting regular people cicadas family
or his daughter died and that's why he
wants to get rid of Meadows so I think
they're gonna try and do everything they
can to humanize cicada like I said
blue-collar villain he's not meant to be
some grand world consuming person like
zoom going to different earths killing
all the flashes trying to steal their
speed all these shots of Cisco acting
weird seem like big setup for a turn at
the end of the episode be prepared for
that there are a lot of theories I've
talked about in previous videos you get
a whole bunch of shots of Caitlin inside
elongated Mans detective agency this is
probably related to the killer frost
search he's the one that gave her the
idea your father faked his murder in the
name of the person that signed the death
certificate is the name of the original
version of icicle from the comics so the
whole idea being that her father may be
a metahuman as well or be the person
that gave her her powers so it sounds
like she's gonna be spending a lot of
time with him we haven't met the new
version of Harrison wells the Sherlock
wells
maybe he shows up at the end of this
episode or in episode 3
he'll be back relatively soon there's
just so much stuff that they have to set
up that they don't want to do everything
all at once you get a little bit of
Barry asking Joe for parenting advice
and how to handle Nora then more of the
showdown with the meta that's trying to
steal all that tech probably before
cicada
jumps on him too because he's also
coming after this same meta that Barry's
getting ready to fight if there's
anything that I didn't mention from the
promo just leave your questions in the
comments below and I'll try to get to it
obviously there's gonna be all kinds of
crossover stuff happening like I said
don't forget that arrow episode 1 is
dropping tomorrow night so make sure you
find a way to watch that I'll post my
video after it airs be sure to turn
alerts on so that you don't miss any of
the videos and obviously new flash
episode on Tuesday so congratulations
truck 10 you're the giveaway winner from
my last big DC video please email me on
the about page of my channel so I can
get your details click here for my new
reverse flash season 5 video and click
here to learn all about spider-man
during Marvel phase 4 thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]